i've just seen what i think
[Music]
i can't believe what
hey buddy just a quick one you know that
you know that conversation we had last
month about boris johnson's new
thing where he was going to help people
with the five percent and all that jazz
yeah you know you were like yeah i'm not
really convinced and i was actually
quite excited about it
yeah we will help turn generation
rent intergeneration buy i am
really excited about boris johnson's
announcement where he said that he's
going to be helping first-time buyers
get on the property ladder by putting
down five percent
and basically we're gonna be able to get
95 percent mortgages again if you're a
first type up i think it's great
russell's a little bit cynical about it
yeah
hold on isn't this kind of like the same
as the help to buy scheme
listen okay hold on you tell me tell me
about the health department okay the
help to buy scheme
is where the government will loan you
the majority of the deposit where you'll
just put down five percent i can see how
you think it's similar five percent yeah
but the difference is with the help to
buy schools they help to buy a scheme
that's forever ending and they're not
ending
yep it's like almost pressure selling
people into using it yeah the government
do that yeah the reason i don't like the
help to buy scheme
is because you have to live in it
yourself for first-time buyers only
but the thing that really kills it is
you can only buy
new build houses what makes you think
that there's not going to be
stipulations for this
all i've said this is why i'm not at all
excited about it because
i'm very excited what how can you be
excited about something you know what it
is i'm excited because okay
i think it's just a help to buy scheme
they've just announced oh we've now
launched a new help to buy scheme up
until however long it's starting from
next month
and it's basically just the worst help
to buy scheme
new build properties only
got to live in it all that stuff it's
just another help to buy skin i think
unless it's a different
scheme unless unless what boris was
talking about was something different
and that just happens they're doing
another help to buy scheme as well but
i just don't know what to think i think
that
it's probably what you suspect
in which guys i'd love to come back on
your channel and mock you
right now i am so pissed off
because i've been tricked i've been
tricked by boris
johnson i think i've been tricked okay
boris johnson please please tell me i'm
wrong on this
folks in the comments maybe i'm stupid
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm maybe i'm
being
maybe i'm being i'm overreacting but i
think here's what's happened
about a month ago boris johnson
announced that he was going to
help first-time buyers with a brand new
initiative
which is going to help first time buyers
get on the property ladder and he said
they could just put down a five percent
deposit now i had conversations with
russell about this
i said to russell it's great it's really
good russell was like
let's just wait for the details russell
was skeptical i was excited
and i think because they just announced
this the government did is on the
government website i think
that the new thing he was talking about
was another
another help to buy scheme
and if it is why is no one talking about
this
because a month ago it was like wow
boris johnson's doing this new thing and
then suddenly quietly it's just like oh
there's a new help to buy scheme
if what boris was talking about a month
ago is this new help to buy scheme
i've just read the t's and c's
to the new help to buy scheme and it is
the worst
scheme ever okay now all of this is my
opinion i might be wrong maybe
maybe boris is gonna is gonna reveal
that that's not the thing it's a
different thing i don't know i don't
know i don't know i don't know i don't
know what to think right now but here's
the new scheme let me explain to you
what boris's new scheme is i can't
believe
i was excited about this i literally
told some of my guys some of my staff i
was like oh there's this new initiative
this is what's happening you can just
put down five percent you're gonna be
able to get 95 percent alone
and they were like excited about it and
now it turns out to be a help to buy
scheme why is the help to buy scheme so
bad because i'm on the gov
gov uk website right now it only applies
to new builds which means
that the government are going to lend
you money to buy a new build
but these new builds are going to be
overpriced and you've got to live in it
and there's all these strings attached
to it
it's another help to buy scheme let me
look at this what it says
okay and this is the really thing that
freaks me out on the government website
there's all this marketing spiel they're
so desperate for you
to get into help to buy the same way as
they're desperate for you to go to
university and get student debt
the government is providing this is on
the government website this is not an
advert she's not a premise she's on the
actual government website
the government is providing more ways to
help families onto the housing ladder
and provide that life-changing moment
when you get the keys to your own home
pass me a bucket this is on the
government website
it sounds like sales talk that feeling
provides you with that feeling that
life-changing
come on alongside first time listen why
am i so
why am i so disappointed by this this is
why i'm so disappointed by this
right because the truth is it's talking
about that feeling
helping help helping people get on the
ladder
i'm not being funny but it has and i
would happily argue
with anyone about this on my channel
like any mp
politician journalist boris johnson
himself
i'd love to have a conversation because
people don't quite get where i'm coming
from because they just don't get it
this is just to help developers sell
okay
now at least the good news is they are
they are
um restricting they are making sure
they're tightening up on developers to
make sure the developers are providing
good accommodation
because what was happening was people
were using the help to buy scheme to buy
terrible properties overpriced they were
getting
all this debt and then the properties
were dropping in value they're being
left in negative equity
and they couldn't even shift or sell the
properties it is just an absolute joke
so
the help to buy scheme this is a really
annoying thing about the help to buy
scheme as well
it's so how can people even understand
this look the government are giving you
a loan
to buy a terrible house that's a
liability not an asset
and then they're charging you interest
after five years how much interest is
really confusing we don't know these are
the t's and c's
pay no interest on the loan for the
first five years interest fees start at
one point seven percent and rise each
year in april by the consumer prices
index including owner occupies housing
costs cpih
plus two percent you may pay a monthly
management fee
how confusing is that i don't really
even understand exactly that i've
like so they're making out they're
helping you and all that and it's just
not true so for all the people
you know from from a few weeks ago that
i was where i was like oh they're
bringing this scheme in isn't it great
i'm really sorry russell was right
russell was right i was wrong it sucks
it's just a stupid another help to buy
sham from the government i'd love to
argue about this with somebody
i don't think it's helping people at all
the only people is helping are the very
very wealthy people
not the poor and middle class